this morning we have the story of a
family in Texas facing huge challenges
after the birth of their conjoined twin
daughters Jamie Lynn and Amy Lynn Finley
those are their names they were born in
October look at this connected to the
abdomen and sharing a single liver oh no
but this week a medical team in Fort
Worth was finally ready to try a
potentially dangerous separation surgery
how did it go Omar via Franco shows us
their incredible effort
she was like doing the uh ultrasound and
then she was looking she said oh there's
the baby's head and I was like well if
that's the baby's head I was like what's
that she's like that's the other baby's
head yeah we were like I was like what
James Finley and Amanda arsonyaga are
the proud parents of two tiny Miracles
but when doctors told the north Texas
couple the Twins were conjoined from the
breastbone to the belly button they were
terrified on the ride home we were like
quiet
and it was kind of sad you're really
thinking of why us it's an extremely
rare condition with a high death rate
conjoined twins that reach and stay
viable after birth at least for the
first few days there's really only about
five to eight of those per year born
last October baby girls Jamie Lynn and
Amy Lynn were lucky just to survive
birth then Dr Jose Iglesias and his team
at Cook Children's Medical Center had to
figure out how to surgically separate
them first one for me first one in 105
year history of Cook Children's Medical
Center the procedure required months of
planning will be one baby re-prep do the
other baby Dr Iglesias and his team even
built models of the twins Anatomy mapped
out surgical plans and choreographed
every move they would need to make
and this past Monday the big day finally
arrived
[Music]
the doctors broke up into purple and
green teams and the girl's nails were
painted in coordinating colors to help
differentiate them you said
from there three anesthesiologists four
pediatric surgeons two plastic surgeons
and 18 other clinical professionals
worked methodically first to separate
the Twins and then to close up their
wounds slowly slowly after an 11 hour
procedure and after months and months of
waiting James and Amanda finally got the
news they were waiting for you have two
babies on two separate beds
you know some like this I'll be brutally
honest with you there is no Playbook
Wednesday the medical team behind the
surgery announced their success to the
world they're going to grow up into the
little girls that they're supposed to be
twins have a special bond but these
little girls now share something else
they're part of a medical miracle when
they get older how are you going to
teach them to share
I don't know
like they said there's no Playbook
for CBS mornings I'm Omar villafranca
Omar beautifully done how many times
watching that story did you go oh number
one that they had the surgery shout out
to Dr Iglesias and the whole team yes
that pulled that off it's you just have
to Marvel at what medicine can do yeah I
I'm Blown Away by what you're saying
Gail which is that these doctors are
able to do something that years ago
would not have been possible or how
about Vlad this is the planet that we
live on that they've never done before I
know I mean as a parent you think okay
you've never done this before but the
trust that you have to put in them and
how they must have been feeling the
pressure of doing it and have the
success it's a great great great story
let's think about surgery yes roller
coaster for them
and a great question at the end how are
you going to teach them the get
there